[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARCO GENOVESE: Hi, everyone.
I'm Marco.
TANISHA RAI: And I'm Tanisha.
MARCO GENOVESE: In the
Security Spotlight,
we heard about the importance
of a zero-trust approach
to security.
TANISHA RAI: And
in our demo today,
we will show you how to
implement zero-trust access
to be more secure
and more productive.
And a quick shout
out to our audience.
This is truly live.
Dive into the chat.
We want to hear from you.
Tell us what you do and
where you're joining from.
We can see you.
Check it out, Marco.
MARCO GENOVESE: Sure enough,
we can see everybody down here.
And we're so excited to interact
and talk to you all today.
If you're still hanging out
in the Next Event website,
click on the blue
button that says
Join the Interactive Experience
to activate these features.
OK.
So let's get into it.
We're going to
cover three things.
One-- how your entire workforce
can securely access legacy
and modern applications
without exposing your network
to attacks, and two--
how you can get
better protection
against threats and data loss
right from within your browser,
and three--
how you can gain visibility
into unsafe activity,
even if users aren't on a
corporate network or device.
And we're going
to do all of this
with BeyondCorp Enterprise.
BeyondCorp Enterprise,
or BCE as we call it,
is Google Cloud's
zero-trust access solution.
With BCE, you can use Chrome
to access apps and resources.
In the background,
Google's network
protects and proxies traffic,
enforcing access policies.
These policies use factors
such as identity, device info,
location, and
third-party signals
to authorize access
to apps and data
that you need to do your job.
TANISHA RAI: That's
awesome, Marco.
So let's get to the good stuff.
Think about it.
How easy is it for
your developers
to work remotely and
securely right now?
We know it's a tough task.
We know that making
life easy for developers
while also protecting
your code is critical.
That's why our new BeyondCorp
Enterprise feature, Client
Connector, is so important.
It enables zero-trust access
to legacy thick client
applications.
MARCO GENOVESE:
Yeah, I think a lot
of people run into that today.
So let's take a look at how
developers would use it.
We set up this laptop
for the Cymbal Group.
TANISHA RAI: By the way,
they're a fictional company.
Cymbal has been around
since the 1970s,
and they haven't modernized
all their applications.
Sound familiar?
One of their main
developer applications
is still hosted in a
private data center.
MARCO GENOVESE: Yeah,
I see this quite a bit.
Until recently,
Cymbal developers
didn't have a way to access
this application remotely
without a VPN.
The security team
had constant concerns
that remote users could
expose the network, or even
worse, their source code,
to attacks or hackers.
But now, using BeyondCorp
Enterprise Client Connector,
they can access client
server apps without a VPN.
Let me show you how
Cymbal developers would
connect via SSH to
their Git repository.
And before I show you, let
me just say, don't blink,
or you might miss it.
It's that simple.
So let's go ahead and swing on
over to our developer machine.
From here, I can simply
open up Google Chrome.
Once Google Chrome
has actually loaded,
you can see I have authenticated
to my Git Application
Repository already.
Up in the right-hand
corner, I simply
click on my Endpoint
Verification Extension.
And from here, I click
on Start Connection.
My endpoint is being
postured in the background,
and a secure connection
is being made to GitLab.
From there, I can simply
then-- once it's turned green,
of course--
minimize my browser.
And then on the
left-hand side, I'm
going to go ahead and open
up my terminal application.
This is my thick
client application.
I'm going to then go
ahead and run a Git clone,
and that's actually going to
pull down the code from Git
to my local machine.
And there's my application
pulled down locally
onto my endpoint.
I know that probably seemed
pretty straightforward.
But what you might not
have noticed was first,
there were no clients.
It's all in the browser you
probably already had open.
Second, in the background,
continuously validating
the identity, and the device,
and a bunch of other factors
is our Identity-Aware Proxy.
And third, our TCP proxy
seamlessly and securely
forwards all the traffic.
The fact that developers
around the world
can do this remotely,
simply, and securely
without all the hassle of
a VPN is pretty awesome.
TANISHA RAI: And with
BeyondCorp Enterprise,
workers are only allowed
access to applications
they're permitted to use.
So we prevent unwanted lateral
movement across the network.
So audience, we want
to know, would you
use this method for remote
access in your organization?
MARCO GENOVESE: Awesome.
Now let's see how your
workforce can securely
access modern web
applications even
from non-corporate devices.
Let's look at how Cymbal does
it for their extended workforce,
their call center contractors.
TANISHA RAI: Meet Rhonda.
She's one of thousands
of remote contractors
who help with
Cymbal's 24/7 support
during the holiday
shopping season.
So, security community,
can you share in our chat--
in the past year,
have you onboarded
new temporary workers?
Did you send them a laptop
or make them install software
so they could be more secure?
MARCO GENOVESE: Looks
like that would be a yes.
Contractors also tend to be
more vulnerable to attacks.
Last year, 44% of organizations
experienced a breach,
and 74% of those
breaches were the result
of giving too much privileged
access to third parties.
So for Cymbal, keeping those
users off the corporate network
decreases the risk
of being exposed
to attacks like ransomware.
And here's where using
BeyondCorp Enterprise
comes through again for Cymbal.
Contractors and other
employees are able to BYOD,
onboard quickly,
and use a device
that they feel comfortable with
while BCE layers of protection
keep them secure.
TANISHA RAI: That
way, Rhonda can
have secure access
from her own device
with clear separation between
work and personal activity.
Let me show you exactly what
she sees as she begins her day.
She first navigates to
her Google Chrome browser,
then she navigates to her
Cymbal Call Center application.
We'll enter in our credentials.
We'll then do two-factor
authentication
with our Titan Security Key.
Now that we've passed
two-factor authentication,
we are in our Cymbal
Call Center application.
You saw Rhonda log into Chrome
with her Cymbal credentials.
This is what we call a
BeyondCorp Protected Profile.
It extends threat
and data protection
as soon as she logs in.
As you can see, our
agentless approach
means no additional software.
She gets right to
work on her own device
rather than picking
up a laptop from IT
and waiting hours while
everything gets configured,
therefore saving time and money.
MARCO GENOVESE:
Awesome demo, Tanisha.
And the thing about
zero-trust access
is that we don't automatically
trust Rhonda just because she
has login credentials.
Authorization is continuous,
not just when she first logs in.
BeyondCorp Enterprise enforces
Cymbal's contractor access
policies based on her
identity and contextual
information about her
device and location
as well as the fact that she's
authenticated with her Titan
key.
So security community,
we want to know--
what do you all use for
multifactor authentication?
SMS code, security keys, maybe
an authentication app, or maybe
something else completely?
Hopefully it's not nothing.
TANISHA RAI: For me, it's
my security key every day,
especially since I don't
always have my phone on me.
MARCO GENOVESE: Yeah, same here.
And they're so easy to use,
and they provide the strongest
protection against phishing.
Regardless of what
you use, some form
of multifactor authentication
is critical for basic security
hygiene.
And we highly recommend it,
especially for remote access.
So let's take a look.
I don't know if
anybody has anything.
Looks like most
people use, let's say,
security keys, B. Awesome.
That's what we love to hear.
So let's get back to Rhonda, who
just authenticated to the, app
and explore how we can integrate
threat and data protection
right from within her browser.
TANISHA RAI: Great.
Let's see her get
to work and show
how BCE protects Cymbal,
their customers, and Rhonda
with ease.
It's been a really busy day.
She doesn't have
enough time to finish
processing a batch of customer
refunds before her next call.
She wants to save the customer
credit card information
to a local file and do the
refunds when things slow down,
but saving the sensitive
information to another location
is against Cymbal's
security policy.
Let me show you her experience.
Let's navigate to
our credit card file,
and let's download
this so Rhonda can
do the refunds at another time.
As you can see, she's blocked.
You can see a message appear
at the bottom that prevents her
from doing so.
MARCO GENOVESE: Yeah, exactly.
You can actually see
where the credit card
PDF has sensitive dangerous
content inside of it.
And I'll show you
a policy that's
been configured for Cymbal that
will detect risky behaviors
just like these.
So let's go ahead and look
at our Administrative Console
here at admin.google.com.
Over on the left-hand side,
you can see the Security menu.
And if you scroll down
underneath Security,
you can actually
see Data Protection.
And we're going to go ahead
and authenticate, obviously,
as administrator securely.
So let's go and type
in our password.
And once I've
authenticated, I'll
be able to go ahead and look
at my data protection policies.
You'll notice here
it says Manage Rule,
so we're going to go ahead
and drill into Manage Rules.
And we can actually see now
the credit card detection
policy that Rhonda is
hitting right here.
We've also got detectors for
things like Social Security
or even detecting code that's
being copied, or pasted,
or shared by the developers.
So as the admin, you
can decide if you
want to automatically block
user actions, as Cymbal
as done here, or if you want to
trigger a warning to the user
instead.
TANISHA RAI: And in addition
to things like credit card
numbers, you can also
set specific DLP policies
to detect file type
as source code.
So that way, you can protect
sensitive information and code
by monitoring, controlling,
or even blocking
what people upload or download.
MARCO GENOVESE: Yeah, exactly.
We can use very
granular policies
for this type of
information in order
to protect against exfiltration.
So we just showed you some of
the types of data protection
policies you can set up.
You can also customize
access policies,
and the changes take
effect in real time.
This is a really big deal
because you get continuous
checking of whether a user
is in or out of policy,
giving you up-to-the-second
security controls.
In fact, let's make an update
here in real time for Rhonda.
So OK, community.
We're going to ask you which
policy we should change.
Is it her location, maybe
her operating system policy,
or whether or not she's on
a corporate-owned device?
Please chime in here.
We'd really love to
understand and hear
what you guys deem important.
While we wait for the
results to come in,
I will say that I see
these kinds of things
all the time with my customers.
They want to be
able to dynamically
change policies depending
on their circumstances.
In particular,
some customers are
really interested in
controlling for location,
perhaps limiting access
to only certain countries.
Additionally, if a company
is going through an org
change or maybe a merger, being
able to change access policies
for select groups of users
or departments in real time
is crucial.
And beyond these three
choices in the poll,
there are many other ways
to customize your access
policies based on what
your organization needs.
So let's go ahead and
look back at the polls.
And it looks like
corporate-owned device.
So awesome.
I love it.
And thanks for
everybody contributing.
Let's go ahead and
do this right now.
So we're going to go
ahead and jump on over
into our GCP Cloud Console.
And from here, we can see
our Identity-Aware Proxy.
We can actually see
our Cymbal GitLab
for Developer application.
We can also see our
Call Center application.
And again, these applications
could be anywhere.
For this demo, they're in GCP.
We're going to go ahead
and select the Call Center
application.
And down at the bottom,
we can see Rhonda over
on the right-hand side, her
application access policy.
Let's go ahead and edit that.
And we're going to go ahead
and remove the existing access
policy that's allowing access
from Europe and the US.
And we're going to go
ahead and delete that one.
And we're going
to add a new role.
We're simply going to go ahead
and select Cloud IP, IP Web App
User.
And then from there, we're
going to go ahead and select
the access policy
which everybody chose.
And that was Require
Corporate Device, right?
OK.
I just want to make sure I
remembered that correctly.
Let's go ahead and
save that in place.
Click Save.
And when we save
that policy, it's
actually going to be propagated
across the world within a very
short period of time.
All of the proxies across
Google's global network
are immediately updated.
So the next time any user tries
to access a protected resource,
they're evaluated against
that new policy set.
We mentioned continuous
authorization earlier,
and this is a key part of that.
Authorization is not
a one-time occurrence.
So even if you
begin a new session,
that doesn't mean you'll
have perpetual access.
TANISHA RAI: Exactly.
And for companies like Cymbal
that employ hourly and temp
workers, the ability
to dynamically update
access conditions is important.
For instance, they could set
these policies so workers only
access applications and
resources during their shift
hours or working days,
or only allow access
from specific geographies.
They also may want to
require that devices
have the most up-to-date
operating systems and security
patches, so this is
an important condition
to manage, especially for
all the contractors using
their own devices.
MARCO GENOVESE: Exactly.
So because Rhonda doesn't meet
that condition which I just
updated, she will no longer be
able to access the Call Center
application.
Now, I think we've
all faced this.
And it's one of the
most frustrating things
about remote access, especially
when you're using a VPN.
You think you should
have access to something,
but for some reason,
it's just not working.
TANISHA RAI: It's the worst.
So let's see if our
real-time change worked.
So when Rhonda tries to open
a new task in the Call Center
application, let's take
a look at what she sees.
Let's navigate back to her home.
And she's denied access as
a result of the change Marco
just did.
But once, again BCE
has Rhonda covered.
She can report this error using
our new feature, the BeyondCorp
Enterprise Policy
Troubleshooter, which
informs end users that
they're blocked and tells them
how to get help quickly.
So as you can see
here, she would
follow the prompt to email
the admin to get help.
Let's go ahead and
email our admin.
Our admin is now notified
of us being blocked.
With BeyondCorp Enterprise
Policy Troubleshooter,
admins can quickly fix issues
that are blocking users,
keeping them productive.
MARCO GENOVESE: Yep, you bet.
Let me show you what
the Cymbal admin would
see on the other
side of this request
and how they could
unblock users like Rhonda.
So we're going to go
ahead and switch gears.
Let's go over to Gmail,
another Google application.
And it looks like we've got a
notification for credit card
detection, which is good.
So we know if Rhonda is taking
some interesting actions
within her endpoint-- oh,
and it looks like we just
got an email from Rhonda
because she's actually
been blocked to an application.
There's the link that she
sent over, so let's go ahead
and click on that.
And we'll automatically
be logged directly
into the Google Cloud platform.
So from here, I can actually
see the different policies
and bindings that are in place.
So let's go ahead and select
the Call Center application.
And over on the
right-hand side here,
we can actually see the granted
conditions or the denials
themselves.
So let's go ahead and look
at the binding details.
So interestingly
here, we can see
that Rhonda failed to meet any
of the listed access levels.
And sure enough, it's
requiring a corporate device
which was not granted.
So I would normally
go back in a blocker
by updating that policy so
her access level is evaluated
like any other
contractor, but we're
going to keep moving just
in the interest of time.
TANISHA RAI: Sounds good.
That was so easy, by the way.
MARCO GENOVESE:
Yeah, super easy.
Now let's look at how BCE
can give us better visibility
into unsafe user
activities, whether they're
unsuccessful access
attempts like we just saw
or other anomalous
activities across the apps
that BCE protects.
Let me pull up the Security
Dashboards in Chrome
and give you all a look.
So we're going to jump back over
into our Google Admin Console
here.
And in the same Security
menu on the left-hand side,
we can actually
click on Dashboards.
We'll wait for those to
load out for a second.
So something to
make note of here
is that with Chrome
data protection,
you're actually going
to get a whole slew
of different information.
We can see Chrome
high-risk users.
We can see individual
DLP incidents.
If we want to scroll
down a little bit,
we could actually
see how many users
are forgetting their
passwords if I can figure out
how to use a trackpad here.
So we can see user
login attempts.
We can see, for example,
messages that are encrypted.
But what we're interested
in is whether or not
those credit card numbers
are making it through.
So let's go ahead and
drill a little bit
into one of these reports.
So we can see every single file
uploaded, file downloaded, web
content upload, for example.
And we can actually
see every single time
that this took place for our
Social Security detection
as well as credit
card detection.
And if we were to actually drill
in on Credit Card Detection
here-- and I think this
is really cool, so I'm
going to show everybody
real quick here since we do
have another minute.
And that is all
the sensitive data
transfers that are taking
place, blocked, detected,
or otherwise.
So even if your
organization isn't
using all
corporate-owned devices,
you can still monitor
security events
and investigate those alerts.
TANISHA RAI: That's
awesome, Marco.
Audience, so what do you think?
Let us know in the chat.
We definitely know this
is something of interest.
In the last 15 minutes, you've
seen how an entire workforce
can access modern and legacy
applications securely,
how you can improve threat
and data protection,
and how you can get better
visibility into risky activity,
even on unmanaged devices.
MARCO GENOVESE: Yeah.
Our goal, at the end of the
day, with BeyondCorp Enterprise
is to make your experience more
productive and more secure.
And our team looks
forward to supporting you
on your zero-trust journey.
TANISHA RAI: Thanks
so much for joining us
today and participating.
We have a live
Q&A coming up next
to answer all of your Google
Cloud Security questions
as well as any questions you
might have had from the demo,
so please stick around.
MARCO GENOVESE: Yeah, please do.
And thank you all for joining.
We'll see you all soon.
TANISHA RAI: Bye.